meine Damen und Herren begrüßen Sie mit
mir ihren heutigen Gastgeber Laser
lu
danke danke danke ach auch wieder da
alles klar alles in Ordnung super danke
fre mich also meine Damen und Herren ich
darf euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einem neuen Video
denn gute Neuigkeiten ich wde endlich in
den Club reingelassen danke das hier ist
auf jeden Fall der nightclub inem
wir oh
oh
hi ich weiß nicht was das hier für
nightclub ist oh
hi
oh warum furzen diese Dinger hier die
ganze
Zeit das hier vorne ist auf jeden Fall
der DJ der
nein nein
nein nein das war aus Versehen ich habe
nichts
gemacht okay er checkt dass es aus
Versehen war
[Musik]
okay alles wie in echt wenn ich im Club
bin können wir hier irgendwie über die
Boxen ho oh jo wir
können Fischer geh mal weg dicker los
geht's
[Musik]
ach du scheiße den
Baseballschläger okay wir müssen
anscheinend doch oh mein Gott zur Waffe
greifen okay wo bist du schieß ich habe
ke ich habe keine Munition mit den
Händen blöd hier nimm das okay jetzt
habe ich Stress mit den Russen ach du
scheiße okay ich muss ganz schnell los
habe ich noch Stress mit irgendw der
Security man ist nicht auf uns
aufmerksam geworden ich würde sagen ich
verstecke mich auf de dancefor und Dance
ein
bisschen ich wollte nicht schlagen ich
woll ich woll
klatschen du machst es super ach du
scheiße ist nicht mehr normal ach du
Kacke jetzt läft mir auch noch hinterher
kann ich irgendwie schneller laufen es
geht nicht ist noch hinter mir
Lauf hier oben ist aber keiner ne das
heißt theoretischen komm her komm her
Idiot komm Biss
Feier du scheiße nein es geht nicht
weiter es
geh wir Ken alles reden a du
scheiße Anschein doch nichtar kein
Stress Freunde wiren das ganze ne finden
uns zurück hier in unserem nightclub und
Tanz jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
[Applaus]
mit K clap clap mach super relationship
11 Klasse hi High
Five High
Five
danke ich habe gehört dass irgend sch
wieder hingefallen ist okay tanst du mal
weiter Abstand danke relationship 26 ach
guck mal das steigert
[Musik]
uns nein jetzt kommt komm tötet mich
einmal ey es tut mir leid ich wollte nur
tanzen ich wollte nur tanzen
a mir auch egal die kläre ich mir gleich
die da vorne die wird die wird gleich
mein
[Musik]
sein ich bin aber schon stabiler Typ
dass ich so lange ausgehalten hab hey
sexy Lady wie ich bei dir super toll ich
plat weiter für dich
relationship 11 hallo wie bei dir super
klasse ach du ach man ihr beiden seid
zusammen wir wissen jetzt also dass wir
nicht mit dem DJ interagieren dürfen
weil er dann komischerweise plötzlich
ein Baseballschläger eine Waffe hat wir
dürfen auch nicht mit ihm Titanic dances
machen weil er dann plötzlich Security
anheuert und sie ist anscheinend die
Freundin von
ihm das heißt ich darf ihr nicht mal
zuklatschen aber die ist süß okay gut
komm wir gehen mal zu den ach dicker die
sind auch zusammen ne ist aber schon ein
bisschen sehr viel hier mit dem
rumtechtelmächteln ach guck mal mit der
Hand auch das geht nicht
tchuldigung das geht nicht hier bei uns
im Club na jetzt will sie mich auch
schlagen oder was komm roundh Kick will
ich
herkommen Brigitte ab in deine hässliche
bootausfresse du dumme was willst du
denn
Michel dier es macht doch keinen Spaß
wenn die ein die ganze Zeit angreifen
ich weiß halt V real nicht so ganz was
wir hier machen können ohne uns mit
Leuten zu boxen sie hier guck mal sie
ist ganz alleine hier vielleicht
schaffen wir da was ich Klatsche mal zu
freut sie sich zumindest darüber nee sie
reagiert gar nicht wie tanzt die
denn was ist denn
[Musik]
das ich frag mich wir ach
Sandra ich hätte gern noch einen für sie
hier meine Freundin Sandra ich nehme
auch selbst alles gut hier
Sandra relationship 3 alles in echt ich
nehme noch mal die eben kurz okay
erstmal ich
verpiss Dich duoh guck mal hier Sandra
einer geht noch
oh sandra will Boxen
Idiot du bist Hack stramm
oh oh das tut mir leid ist das jetzt
wieder irgendwer gesehen nee guck mal
ach hier die besoffenen ist in Ordnung
ne hier komm zack Tanz mal ein bisschen
Sandra alles gut Zeit Zeit komm Sandy
ich gehe auch nach
unten und jetzt geh mal
oh
guck mal ich habe ein Security getötet
was jetzt los Security ist weg du
kleiner Idiot ne du willst auchkommen
guck mal wie du läufst wie du läufst wie
ein ballerin wo will hin ich bin hier
komm her komm her ich geb dir ein seit
Zeit s selbst guck mal wo dein Abend
schon ist bleib mal unten besser ist es
wiederunter du komm wier runter du
kommst wieder runter geh runter danke
Peter guck mal bisschen
Kohle willst jetzt mit mir
rumlecken oh ich glaub die freuen sich
wartet mal ab was ich euch jetzt geb
hier
hallo
ich lass sie vorne hier mal machen ich
glaube sie hat eh kein Bock mehr auf
mich ne die will mich ausschlagen er
auch ich geh nach Hause ich geh nach
Hause ich
[Musik]
gehe ich mein ich kann es verstehen
Madame ne ich würde mich auch nicht
Daten mit solchen Schuhen an der Stelle
würde ich das heutige Virtual Reality
Video jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine Damen und Herren wenn euch das
ganze gefallen hat dann
lasst seh nicht